former Secretary of State Fox News
contributor let's give a warm welcome to
Mike pompeo's with
us Mr
secretary why would Joe Biden as they
now as Israel has now begun the ground
operations why would he be calling for a
temporary ceasefire why would the
president not stand with Israel and say
go defeat your enemy and win the war
Sean there's there's no logical
explanation uh if you put America First
you definitely want prime minister
Netanyahu to do both uh his duty that is
to destroy Hamas uh and to complete that
mission in its entirety and you don't
need him having a second front here in
America right you're fighting Hamas and
now you're fighting the Biden
Administration fighting a Biden
Administration that is clearly just
simply lost its way it for it forgets
already now just short of four weeks
what actually happened there and is
trying to sort of to to restrain them
and to hear Senator Durban talk about a
ceasefire in exchange for hostages look
we want all these hostages home we want
every American home we've had Americans
killed but make no mistake about it if
if if netan were to take that deal and
get the hostages out in exchange for
allowing Hamas to continue to threaten
Israel it would only result in the death
of more Israelis and more Americans and
then lastly Sean you know I heard
President Biden speak today and I heard
secretary blink can speak today neither
of them identified the real problem set
here which is Iran they continue to
cotle they given him $70 billion it has
fueled and set the context for the
barbaric actions of which you spoke and
prime minister nyaho has spoken uh to
give Iran More Money More Time a
ceasefire would only create enormous
risk for Israel for the gulf Arab states
that are having Rockets fired from Yemen
and for us here at home in America as
well how bad can this get we already see
the possibility of a two front War uh
Hamas Gaza hisbah Lebanon the the houis
uh the rebels in Yemen declaring war
against Israel Syria firing Rockets into
Israel uh now erdogan and turkey
threatening to get militarily involved
and the mullers in Iran they're doing
their saber rattling how bad can this
get what is the worst case scenario in
your
mind so there's enormous risk that this
expands uh it expands in ways that cause
the Arab states to have to uh check out
because they don't feel like the United
States has their back because President
Biden called uh the Crown Prince of
pariah uh the North Koreans have talked
about providing Weapons Systems we know
the Russians are already on the ground
in Syria uh this could spread not only
to uh the greater Middle East uh you
could certainly have uh not only cyber
attacks but cells that are sitting in
Europe cells that may well be in the
United States we heard our FBI director
talk about that uh just this past week
no if United States doesn't lead if we
don't reestablish the very deterrence
that the Trump administration had in
place for four years on which nothing uh
nothing like we've seen in these three
years has happened right there was no
war in Europe and there was no war in
the Middle East for four years uh if if
we lose that deterrence if America is
viewed as weak this could expand
dramatically and we should all be
reminded as well xingping is watching
America's actions as well and the
Chinese Communist party is sitting there
just hoping that America will
demonstrate that is impotent and
decadent and unprepared to do the things
that will protect its own citizens not
only abroad but its own Southern border
I was speaking to a somewhat skeptical
um interviewer tonight and I I brought
up the issue that I believe when you and
president Trump at the time put together
a coalition I didn't think I'd see this
Coalition in my lifetime and that
included the United States Israel it
included Egypt it included Jordan it
included the Saudis it included the
Emirates it led to the Abraham Accords
but that was unprecedented all standing
against Iranian hegemony in that region
all standing against a nuclear armed
Iran all of that seems to have fallen
apart to what extent did did your peace
through strength policy your policies
and president Trump's policies make a
difference and how does you think these
these World actors are reacting to both
presidents you know Sean we were pretty
clear uh we were going to put America
first uh and when we drew red lines we
were going to enforce them when General
solomani was threatening American
soldiers in Iraq we made sure he didn't
kill any Americans uh when we saw Bad
actors in different places we didn't
send the 82nd Airborne we used America's
power uh and we isolated the bad guys
Iran was never as isolated as it was
during the four years of the Trump
Administration and that let exactly what
you described it it let the Israelis the
Saudis the amadis the bahrainis the
sudanes the Moroccans all of them they
let them all join together and say
America's going to be with us if we have
a bad day and it gave them the capacity
to push back against the world's largest
state sponsor of Terror who is the
Ayatollah you know we're now just a
couple days past the anniversary when
that same regime held Americans in tan
at our Embassy and today the president
spoke of prisoners these aren't
prisoners these are hostages that are
being held inside of the Gaza Strip and
the United States weakness has provided
the context which Hamas felt like it
could do this with absolute impunity and
now you have the American president and
Democrat leaders demanding get that very
impunity be granted to them and I have
no idea why the Obama Biden
Administration and now the Biden
Administration wants to uh give billions
of dollars to Iran it makes no sense or
allow them to sell their oil and become
a oil Rich Nation when they're the
number one state sponsor of Terror
secretary Pompeo great to have you sir
thank you we appreciate it all right hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else